THAT UKRAINE IS PREPARING TO
USE A DIRTY BOMB.
IT IS A CLAIM THAT IS BEING
DISMISSED AS A POSSIBLE FALSE
FLAG JUSTIFYING A RUSSIAN
NUCLEAR RESPONSE.
THE U.S. UK AND FRANCE EVEN
ISSUING THIS RARE JOINT
STATEMENT AND IT READS IN PART.
THE DEFENSE MINISTERS OF EACH
OF OUR COUNTRIES SPOKE TO
RUSSIAN DEFENSE MINISTER AT HIS
REQUEST.
OUR COUNTRIES MAKE CLEAR WE ALL
REJECT RUSSIA'S TRANSPARENT
FALSE ALLEGATIONS THAT UKRAINE
IS PREPARING TO USE A DIRTY
BOMB ON ITS OWN TERRITORY.
THE WORLD WOULD SEE THROUGH ANY
ATTEMPT TO USE THIS ALLEGATION
AS A PRETEXT FOR ESCALATION.
PUTIN LAYING THE GROUNDWORK FOR
A FALSE FLAG ATTACK THAT ALLOWS
FOR NUCLEAR ESCALATION BECAUSE
HIS CONVENTIONAL FORCES ARE
LOSING.
TONIGHT WE FOUND MORE NEW VIDEO
OF RUSSIAN SOLDIERS TALKING
ABOUT THEIR DIRE REALITY.
>> JUST TAKE A LOOK AT OUR
UNIFORMS.
EACH OF THESE WE BOUGHT
OURSELVES.
ALL OF OUR GEAR WE PURCHASED
OUR MASKS ARE COMBAT BOOTS ARE
GLOVES.
ONE GUY BOUGHT A FLAT JACKET
FOR 60,000 RUBLES.
BY THE SAME EVENING THE PRICE
HAD ALREADY GONE UP TO 80,000
RUBLES.
NOW THAT SAME FLAT JACKET COST
100 TO 150,000 RUBLES.
WE KNOW HOW THIS WORKS.
BUT EVERY TIME WE GO TO ANOTHER
STORE THE PRICE KEEPS GOING UP
TWO TIMES WHAT IT WAS BEFORE.
I WILL ADD A COMMENT ABOUT THE
WEAPONS.
WHICH WERE RUSTY AND JAMMED.
SUCH WEAPONS ARE NOT FIT FOR
BATTLE.
WE HAVEN'T BEEN FED FOR 2 DAYS.
THERE WASN'T EVEN ANY WATER.
>> AGAIN THEY ALL WANT TO BE
SEEN.
HE WANTED TO KNOW THEY ALL
AGREE.
THEY COVERED THEIR FACE SO YOU
CANNOT FULLY IDENTIFY WHO THEY
ARE.
WHEN IT COMES TO RUSSIAN
LEADERSHIP.
PUTIN IS SEEMING TO THREATEN TO
ESCALATE THE WAR IN OTHER WAYS.
TONIGHT I WANT TO KNOW ABOUT
TWO MORE RUSSIANS ARRESTED FOR
PHOTOGRAPHING MILITARY
FACILITIES IN NORWAY IS A NATO
COUNTRY.
ACCORDING TO NORWEGIAN TV.
IN RECENT WEEKS SEVERAL RUSSIAN
NATIONALS WITH DRONES HAVE BEEN
ARRESTED AND DETAINED IN
NORWAY.
INCLUDING THE SON OF THIS PUTIN
ALLY WHO WAS ARRESTED FOR
FLYING A DRONE IN A SENSITIVE
AREA.
NORWAY CARRIES THEM IN
STRATEGIC VALUE IN THIS WAR.
NORWAY IS NOW EUROPE'S TOP GAS
SUPPLIER AFTER RUSSIA CUT
SUPPLIES.
LIVE IN UKRAINE TONIGHT.
FRED WHAT IS THE LATEST ON THE
GROUND WHERE YOU ARE TONIGHT?
>> Reporter: WE WERE NEAR THE
SOUTHERN FRONT END THIS WAR
THAT IS GOING ON.
WHAT UKRAINIANS ARE SAYING THAT
THE BATTLE FOR -- THEY SAY THEY
CONTINUE TO MAKE A LOT OF
HEADWAY THERE.
THE BIG QUESTION HERE RIGHT NOW
IS WHAT IS THE RUSSIAN MILITARY
GOING TO DO NEXT IN THAT AREA?
ARE THEY GOING TO WITHDRAWAL OR
ARE THEY GEARING UP TO MAKE
SOME STAND OR IS THERE THE
POTENTIAL FOR A DRAMATIC NEW
ESCALATION?
HERE IS WHAT WE ARE LEARNING.
>> AS UKRAINIAN FORCES CONTINUE
TO MAKE GAINS IN THE SOUTH OF
THE COUNTRY MOSCOW ACCELERATING
THE EVACUATION OF PEOPLE FROM
THE AREA AROUND.
FAIRIES BRINGING TENS OF
THOUSANDS ACROSS THE -- RIVER.
THE RUSSIANS TO SAFETY UKRAINE
SAYS THESE ARE ESSENTIALLY
DEPORTATIONS.
>> MY MOTHER NEEDS MEDICAL
TREATMENT.
SHE IS ILL.
AND OF COURSE WE ARE AFRAID FOR
OUR LIVES.
WE LIVE NOT FAR FROM THE --
BRIDGE.
I THINK EVERYTHING WILL BE FINE.
-- WILL HOLD OUT.
>> Reporter: OFFICIALS BELIEVE
THIS COULD BE THE BEGINNING OF
A FULL RUSSIAN RETREAT FROM
THIS AREA.>> COLLABORATORS ARE
LEAVING THE WEST PART OF THE
REGION IN QUITE A DRAMATIC WAY.
THIS HAPPENS ALONG WITH THE
TOTAL -- CITY AND THE REGION
WEST OF THE RIVER.
>> Reporter: BUT UKRAINE'S
MILITARY INTELLIGENCE SAY THEY
BELIEVE RUSSIA IS ACTUALLY
BUILDING UP ITS FORCES HERE FOR
A MASSIVE STAND RATHER THAN
READYING FOR WITHDRAWAL.
BUT AS VLADIMIR PUTIN'S TROOPS
LOSE GROUND OFFICIALS IN MOSCOW
ARE MAKING TROUBLING
ACCUSATIONS.
IN A CALL WITH SECRETARY OF
DEFENSE LLOYD AUSTIN RUSSIA'S
DEFENSE MINISTER ALLEGING
WITHOUT ANY EVIDENCE THAT
UKRAINE IS PLANNING TO DETONATE
A NUCLEAR LACED IMPROVISED
DEVICE A SO-CALLED DIRTY BOMB.
>> RUSSIAN GENERAL ADDING TO
THE CLAIMS>> THE PROVOCATION IS
AIMED AT ACCUSING RUSSIA OF
USING WEAPONS OF MASS
DESTRUCTION AT THE UKRAINIAN
THEATER OF OPERATIONS THAT WILL
LAUNCH A POWERFUL ANTI-RUSSIAN
CAMPAIGN IN ORDER TO UNDERMINE
THE CONFIDENCE IN MOSCOW.
>> Reporter: SHARPLY REJECTS
OBLIGATIONS EVEN ASKING THE
INTERNATIONAL ATOMIC ENERGY TO
INSPECT HIS CIVILIAN NUCLEAR
SITES.
THE IA ALREADY HAS STAFF IN THE
-- NUCLEAR PLANT TRYING TO
PREVENT AN ATOMIC DISASTER THEY
ARE.
UKRAINE'S PRESIDENT HURLING THE
ALLEGATIONS BACK AT MOSCOW.
>> NEVER AGAIN WILL RUSSIA BE
ABLE TO DICTATE ANYTHING TO
ANYONE.
IT NO LONGER HAS THE POTENTIAL
TO DICTATE.
THE WORLD SEES THAT.
RUSSIAN POTENTIAL IS BEING
WASTED NOW IN THIS MADNESS ON A
WAR AGAINST OUR STATE AND THE
ENTIRE FREE WORLD.
>> Reporter: THE RUSSIANS
CONTINUE TO HIT UKRAINE WITH
LONG-DISTANCE MISSILES AND
DRONES THIS WEEKEND.
THE RUSSIANS ARE CONTINUING
THEIR AIR CAMPAIGN AGAINST THE
PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE OF THIS
COUNTRY HITTING CIVILIAN AREAS
LIKE RIGHT HERE.
KILLING AND WOUNDING SCORES OF
PEOPLE.
BUT THE AIR CAMPAIGN IS ALSO
TAKING A MASSIVE TOLL ON THE
ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE OF THIS
COUNTRY LEAVING HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS WITHOUT POWER.
THE UKRAINIAN SAY RUSSIANS
AIRSTRIKES WON'T STOP THEIR
ADVANCE.
ARMY LOOKING TO RETAKE AS MUCH
AS THEY ARE TERRITORY AS
POSSIBLE FOR WINTER SETS IN.
>> CERTAINLY FROM OUR VANTAGE
POINT IN THE SOUTH OF THE
COUNTRY IT LOOKS AS THOUGH
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S ARMY IS IN A
LOT OF TROUBLE.
PRECARIOUS SITUATION AROUND
THAT TOWN OF --.
WHERE THE LOGISTICS ARE
EXTERNALLY DIFFICULT.
IF UKRAINIANS HIT SOME KEY
BRIDGES THEY A